[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
concerto à quatre mains à quatre mains
sont ligue 2 au wii dont tu dans ta
gueule
allez-y maïs trop haut mais mais mais
mais mais mais mais tu es mon fils et ma
plus belle année
[Applaudissements]
allez go
[Musique]
ma plus belle
on se bat
et
tu me donner
[Applaudissements]
je suis jamais
de terre
[Musique]
suspension c'est ça être père
[Applaudissements]
l'artiste
mathieu bat mathieu c'est moi tu sais il
ya des soirs comme ça où tout
s'écroule autour de nous
sans trop savoir pourquoi toujours
regardez devant soir
n'ont jamais baissé les bras je sais
je suis pas le remède à tous
mais fausse mort c'est parfois mathieu
mathieu dépêche-toi
on vit
on ne meurt qu'une fois
[Musique]
et on n'a toujours rien
c'est déjà la fin mais c'est pas marqué
dans les livres
que plus important à vivre c'est de
vivre au jour le jour
le temps c'est l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous en portant un livre
c'est le niveau au jour le jour le temps
ces médailles
c'est de l'amour
[Musique]
mais c'est pascal bats chandelle merci
bocal roland pascal schultz
mais tant qu'on tient dans toute la
preuve selon pascale heylen fort un
artiste exceptionnel un génie